- Social media is a
treasure trove of good news
when you know where to look,
but you don't even have to look,
because I've got you covered.
This is, "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
Anyone who has been here,
knows New York is one of
the most diverse cities
on the planet.
It's what I love about it.
In fact, people speak
more than 700 languages,
across the five boroughs.
That's crazy.
Well, there's a New Yorker whose attempts
to learn some of those languages,
especially the more obscure ones,
have made him a viral
star, check this out.
- And where are all these clothes from?
- Nigeria.
- Nigeria? Oh.
(man speaks Yoruba)
(lady laughs)
(lady speaks Yoruba)
(man speaks Yoruba)
- Oh American, yes.
(woman speaks Yoruba)
- Maybe like next week.
- [Man In Black Tshirt] You try, you try.
(audience cheers)
- Say hello to Arieh Smith, y'all.
(audience applauds)
I mean that was incredible.
First of all,
their reactions to you
speaking were incredible,
but you were speaking a
Nigerian language called,
is it Yoruba?
- Yoruba. Yoruba.
- Yoruba?
- With the tones Yoruba.
- Yoruba, okay.
And you were speaking that in the clips.
So how many languages do you know?
- Yeah, so to be honest,
the languages that I speak
decently well probably only four.
- Well, you lazy man.
(audience laughs)
Only four.
- Yes.
So I speak English, Mandarin,
Cantonese and Spanish.
But really over the past
year I've been studying,
you know, 15 or so languages
somewhat simultaneously.
If you look at New York,
every neighborhood has its own little...
Like you have one neighborhood
that's like entirely African,
you have another neighborhood
that's like entirely Russian,
so learn these languages
and go down there,
(Arieh coughs)
- What a way to connect with people.
- Yeah it's really incredible.
I think it makes people feel
seen and I think it makes-
- [Kelly] It's shifting
the narrative. I like it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Thank you Arieh.
- I really appreciate that,
I really do appreciate it.
- It's so cool what you're doing.
I'm liking your posts right now.
And also this is our first
time ever doing this live.
(audience cheers)
So that's not all though, our
season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show
thinks you're incredible, as we do,
So in recognition, they'd
like to write you a check
with their G2 gel ink pen
for a thousand dollars.
- What!
- [Kelly] How's that sound?
You make more videos!
- Thank you